hello everyone welcome to another
episode of unlocking lily it's always
been my dream to be a speaker which led
me to quit my day job to work and mentor
under Evan full-time and all of you are
coming along for the ride with me in
every episode I take on a different
challenge really helped me grow as a
speaker in this video I'm gonna be
taking on the biggest challenge yet I'm
gonna be doing my first TEDx talk and
all of you are coming on the road trip
with me matter of fact I'm leaving right
now so I'm gonna see you guys on the
road very very soon we just survived in
Michigan it's about 11:30 at night we're
gonna go check into the hotel the lovely
people at TEDx actually offered to pay
for our hotel State which is really nice
and them
I'm surprising since it's a nonprofit
organization so super nice coming out of
their pockets we go check out this hotel
catch you soon have checked in this is
our room it's quite nice and comfy
tomorrow's a big day we're gonna have a
dress rehearsal it's getting kind of
late so we're gonna change and go to
sleep we're just gonna I'm gonna
honestly I want to find this place by
using this Sun we're trying to figure
out how to get to the TEDx place because
we have no GPS GPS none of our internet
connection is working so we're going to
try to get there by following this on my
phone yeah son yes yes hopefully we get
there soon before my dress rehearsal
starts by the time it's gonna be
interesting I'm gonna get wealthy
wealthy TEDx here we go
so we finally made it to the Livonia
Civic Center library where the TEDx
event is going to be taking place I'm
feeling good I'm not feeling nervous
quite yet maybe because it feels it's a
real it doesn't feel like it's real so
we're gonna go in and maybe the nerves
will kickin or maybe I might not get
nervous at all
[Music]
everyone I just finished my dress
rehearsal
it was so nervous oh my god
I was speaking really fast and I
couldn't figure out the clicker thing oh
my goodness and I'm so glad that I had
this rehearsal cuz I feel like I got all
my nerves out of the way and now I know
how I'm gonna do things differently yeah
I just didn't expect it I was just kind
of sitting back thinking that oh yeah I
got this I practiced there about 200
times and it's so Jeff rend when you're
up there gosh I think it's gonna be a
lot better tomorrow though I think so
but but people are super supportive they
were so nice and they did the exercises
I asked them to do it was all good but
yeah tomorrow's gonna be a lot better
than today
so today is the day I'm just getting
ready to leave I'm really excited I'm
really really excited I'm not nervous
I am excited and this morning I was just
listening to some music that make me
feel you know pumped and ready to go and
feeling extraordinary and I'm just
thinking about when I'm gonna be on
stage and how it's gonna be and I really
don't want it to end it at all feel like
they have to pry me off the stage we'll
see well I'll try and linger as long as
possible it's you know it's something
that I've been working on for such a
long time and it's finally here I don't
want it to be over so quickly I'll catch
you guys soon when I do my speech
[Music]
so it's nine minutes before showtime I
may be taking on the stage of very very
soon not to be quiet because it's white
here
[Music]
know everyone so it's about eight
o'clock we wrapped up TEDx talk the
first TEDx talk ever that I have done
which was amazing it went really well it
went better than I thought which is
quite amazing because I thought it would
I would be pretty awesome and it
actually went better than I thought I'm
gonna try to digest everything that has
happened today I'm gonna think about it
tonight think about it tomorrow morning
on our way home and we're gonna go back
to hotel catch some snooze and we're
going to be heading back to Toronto
very soon oh this is Evan so I am back
for my TEDx talk I'm just thinking about
all the great things that happen during
the conference the organizers working so
hard tires Leah round the clock to make
sure that everything ran smoothly the
speakers were awesome they had such
great things to share and I feel like I
learned a lot from them and we also made
a connection so we're gonna keep in
contact with each other for a while and
the audience the audience they were so
supportive and they came up to me after
my talk and we had conversations and I
made some connections there as well so
I'm super grateful in all the things
that happened during the talk and now
thinking back to my own talk I thought
I'd share three things that went really
well for me and three things that I
could improve on so I'm gonna start off
by telling you three things that I did
really well number one is I maintained
within the time limit as a speaker
you're always gonna be given a certain
amount of time that your speech is
supposed to be so in the TEDx world your
speech cannot be longer than 18 minutes
so for me I was particularly nervous
because weeks leading up to my talk if
my speech was still about 20 minutes
long or so so it took a lot of practice
and editing it down and cutting it back
and back and back and practice practice
practice to finally get it down to 18
minutes
number two is engaging
audience I wanted to create a talk that
was more conversational and more
interactive so I got them to do stuff
like hugging each other I got them to
raise their hands when I asked a
question
I even got them to answer one question
for me it was really high-risk because
the potential of it going wrong was
highly likely there could have been a
complete dead silence and nobody
answering my questions or everyone
reluctant to raise their hands but I
went in with so much conviction because
it's something that I really wanted to
do to kind of draw the audience in to
kind of be part of my talk versus just
observing that it ended working out
really well for me number three is my
emotional commitment whether it was
sadness frustration happiness all of
that I committed myself fully into it
this is a part that I struggle with the
most when I was going through the
practice sessions I was telling the
stories I wasn't feeling it and I'm so
glad I put in the extra time to really
practice over and over again that I was
able to get all the emotions out as well
now the three areas of improvement
number one power point oh my goodness I
totally underestimated the power of
power points it really captivates the
audience if you have a nice visual
presentation to go along with your voice
as well I didn't spend nearly enough
time as I should have practicing with a
PowerPoint as well as investing into
making the powerpoints visually stunning
so definitely next time around practice
practice practice with a PowerPoint for
sure for sure for sure number two is my
voice I don't realize how quiet I was be
on stage until I saw the video of myself
speaking I could have definitely
projected my voice a lot further than I
did and also the variation of my voice I
could have played around with the speed
and the tempo of it which could have
made it more interesting for people to
hear
so lots and lots of vocal lessons for me
to get my voice up there for my next
talk
number three is a stronger ending there
wasn't anything wrong with the words
that I use but I could have brought way
more conviction that I did for the call
to action in the end the whole reason
why I want to be a speaker is to spark a
change in people and for people to take
action after hearing my talk so if I
brought way more confidence and way more
conviction in the end I feel like more
people will be willing to go out there
and take action so I'm quite a few
people asked me how I got my TEDx talk
so for my next challenge I'm going to
share with all of you how I landed my
first TEDx talk so the question of the
day is what is your one big goal that
you're working on right now write in the
comments below and I'll join it on the
discussion
I have a special shadow for Donna
Osbourne Donna Osbourne wrote your
amazing Lily you inspire me to work on
making my own magic happen and move away
from playing it safe yes Donna thank you
so much for writing that beautiful
comment and that's what we want we want
you to make more magic happen thanks
again Donna so thank you so much for
watching and more importantly being on
this journey with me some of you have
been with me since DeWine it's crazy and
I really hope that I get to meet you in
person one day so I could give you like
a big giant hug to thank you for all the
love and the support you've been giving
me so far and I will see you very very
soon